welcome back everyone so we've been
talking about extreme seeking control
and we've been applying this in MATLAB
with some simple some simple system here
we basically took a static objective
function and built it very very simple
extreme seeking controller to track to
optimize that optimizing control and put
you that maximizes this objective
function we also wrote a script to
essentially show what this would look
like in a digital a digital loop and now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
show you how you can apply extreme
seeking control to a very challenging
dynamical system that would be very hard
to control this is an example that's
actually from Karthik and Chris --tx
book on extreme seeking control from
2003 wiley so I encourage you to go
check that out if you want more details
on how they actually chose the system
and designed it but this is basically a
system that was designed to be about as
nasty as possible okay so you have some
objective function f basically you know
we're going to step our objective
function there's some ramp in the the
optimizing control U star so the the u
that optimizes the subjective function
is ramping linearly there's going to be
a step and discontinue a step in the
optimal value of J and in addition to
that that static objective function
where the U star is is varying and J has
the step in time this gets multiplied by
input dynamics and output dynamics so
there will be actual dynamical systems
some OD es some transfer functions on
the inputs and outputs here and here
that give this thing its own internal
dynamics and timescales making it much
much more challenging to control in
particular I think that they've given
this thing a right half-plane zero which
makes it very difficult to control so
that means that this will be non minimum
phase if I ramp my you my system
actually turns in the wrong direction
for a little bit before it then goes up
and so I think this this is a very very
hard system if you were going to even
have the equations it would be hard to
design a good control law but here we're
going to assume we don't actually know
what the equations are
we're gonna like tune this thing to
control it so this is a kind of a power
demonstration of extremum seeking
control on a very challenging control
problem with a right half-plane zero a
changing optimum u star and a
discontinuous jump in the dynamics in
this objective function at some time but
the basic architecture is the same so
here what I'm doing is I have my output
function plus these these dynamics I
have a bunch of blocks that dump data to
the workstation to the to the to
matlab's environment so that I can plot
theta which is the optimizing u I can
plot the cost function J I have this
thing to add my sinusoidal perturbation
and then basically this is all the same
as what we've been doing before I have a
high-pass filter I have an integrator I
multiply a phase shifted version of my
input sinusoid but here I'm adding some
sensor noise so I'm assuming that my
measurement of the subjective function
is a little bit noisy so it's it's an
imperfect measurement I have sensor
noise and in this case Karthik and
Christic actually showed that you had
two phase shift this demodulating sine
wave to get it to work so this is a
really hard example where you have two
phase shift it their integrator is also
not just a one over s simple integrator
it's more of like a washout low-pass
plus integrator it's a funky integrator
I'm gonna actually zoom in and look so
it's 50 s minus 200 divided by s minus
0.01 okay so it's not a perfect
integrator but it's got these kind of
big gain and some other some other
dynamics okay so long story short you
take the basic extreme seeking control
loop or your high pass filter demodulate
and integrate with some sinusoidal
perturbation and mostly nothing changes
but you tweak the integrator a little
bit's and you phase shift the
perturbation signal and those allow you
to kind of tune the system to control
this very very challenging system okay
so I'm just going to run this we're
gonna see what the output is and see
that it actually works this is also the
code for this is on line
is also in in in our book my book with
Nathan cuts on data-driven science and
engineering so you can see some of the
output figures and run the code yourself
okay I'm gonna run this let's hope
everything works it compiles it's
running it's running it's ready and so
I've dumped all of this stuff to the to
the to the what is it called the
workspace so now I can plot the control
knob theta so theta is my theta is the
the control that the system is actually
commanding it should be a ramp that
optimizing control is a ramp and we can
also plot the output Y when it tracks
this the step so let's let's just play
around with this a little bit so I'm
gonna try let's see plot let's see if I
have a t variable I'm not sure if I
there is such a t let's plot theta okay
so this is that control knob and
basically it's trying to track this
linear ramp and it's actually doing a
decent job so notice that this big
hiccup right here that's where the the
cost function had a big jump from a step
from zero to one at time one okay so the
control is doing its thing there's this
massive change in the system dynamics so
there's this huge correction to you but
then it actually gets back on the right
track pretty quickly and tracks this
linear ramp so that's very impressive I
think especially considering that this
is non minimum phase and it has a right
half-plane zero
let's also plot why the outputs so this
is the objective function this is also
pretty cool so the objective function
the optimal J goes from 0 to 0.05 at
time one and you can see that even
though this thing has nasty nonlinear
dynamic sorry not non-linear but non
minimum phase dynamics sensor noise all
of this this nastiness when the system
changes at time one the controller
almost immediately compensates and
--nails
very like rock-solid objective function
output even though the control is doing
this crazy
trajectory and it's tracking this this
ramping you star the optimizing control
input is changing its drifting but the
output doesn't notice any of this so so
even if I had this really nasty system
if I clipped on the special extreme C
can control off as far as the output is
concerned when the system changes I
immediately track and maintain optimal
performance even though under the hood
the controller is just like massively
compensating for these dynamics so I
think this is a very very cool example I
love that this was you know one of the
showcase examples in Karthik and Chris
textbook because this is a super hard
system they took their method and
applied it to just a really really nasty
problem and it works it works great so
play around with this you know honestly
it'll take a little time even understand
why their system is so hard to control
try to design a different controller for
it and then play around with some of the
knobs change the you know change the
filter frequency changes the integrator
gain change all of those things and see
see how this performs okay so that's it
you've seen extremis you can control on
a simple static objective function as an
illustration but now you've seen it
applied to a very nasty hard to control
system and I think you're ready to start
trying this on on your own systems of
interest okay thank you